la visite est sous très haute sécurité
Joe Biden et volodimeki côte à côte dans
la capitale Kiev alors que les sirènes
d'alerte aériennes retentissent tout un
symbole presque un an jour pour jour
après le début de l'offensive russe à
grande échelle
[Musique]
un an plus tard Kiev est toujours debout
et l'Ukraine est toujours debout la
démocratie tiens bon et l'occasion pour
le président américain de réitérer son
soutien indéfectible à l'Ukraine et de
faire une série d'annonces nous
annonçons la livraison de plus de
javelot de plus de 6 radars de
surveillance aérienne pourrait protéger
les yeux craéniens contre les
bombardements aériens un petit peu plus
tard cette semaine nous allons annoncer
des sanctions supplémentaires contre les
élites et les entreprises
russes et grâce à une
décision bip artisan au Congrès nous
apportons un nouveau soutien des
milliards de dollars de soutien un
soutien militaire et financier massif à
l'heure où l'Ukraine paye le prix fort
pour garder le contrôle dans le don
basse et en particulier à barmouth
alors pour Zelenski cette rencontre est
une opportunité de plus pour rappeler
les besoins cruciaux de son armée en
munitions de longue portée de char avec
un objectif reprendre les territoires
occupés nous avons exercé une pression
sur cet état terroriste nous avons
renforcé les sanctions bilatérales et
par le biais du G7 ce qui est très
important un projet de résolution pour
soutenir la paix en Ukraine sera
présenté aux Nations Unies
et le 24 février
nous espérons que cette résolution
montrera
que un état voyou ne pourra jamais
briser un pays civilisé de son côté
Vladimir Poutine doit prendre la parole
ce mardi un discours important selon le
Kremlin lors duquel il est censé exposer
les prochains objectifs de son pays